what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to a
kevin samuels video
titled what's wrong with wearing my damn
bonnet before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell as you guys know
i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers that's a big goal for the
channel each and every one of you
helps me get to that goal and while
you're at it ring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified
of my daily videos okay
um this was sent to me on instagram so
if you guys have clips
that you want me to react to dm them to
me on instagram
and that's the best way to read
i cannot say what's wrong
hello i'm just wondering if you remember
me
okay uh no i can't even okay
you need to back up
yeah i'm in the house
uh-huh yeah you're the girl whose uh
father was spending all the money
yeah i'm back to to to let you know i
have completely changed my life and made
it 316.
the 360 put you right back where you
were but i understand what you're saying
hey i made a 180. are you smoking
so what do you mean you made a 180 how
i changed the way that i've been living
my life
um i found i already i feel like he's
gonna go in and say that she hasn't
like because she's smoking she's
overweight clearly
i don't know i have a feeling he's gonna
be like no you have it
lord and uh i got a man that's got money
now
you found the lord yeah where'd you find
him at i don't know he was lost
i didn't know where the lord was hmm
okay
now now this is all inside of last four
months right
probably like yeah like three months
four months
yeah it's a lot of changing in three or
four months you said you got a man that
has money now
yeah just because you date someone with
money that doesn't mean you change
i didn't look oh look at kevin's face i
just wanted to let you know
also i wear my bonnet in public
and um i saw i saw what you had to say
about that
you know i get where you're coming from
but at the same time
look at his face
at the same time you what did you tell
me shut up
no no no i said go ahead you said at the
same time
at the same time i just don't see what
the issue of wearing a bonded in public
is
you're trying to say it makes us lazy or
whatever you see my hair
okay i just got out of the shower i'm
you know my hair is not
done it's it's wet what if i were to go
outside in this humid outside are you
telling me i can't wear my body because
i'm telling you you can't do a damn
thing i'm saying you can act however you
want it
and you get the outcomes you get right
but why would they ghetto
for someone to worry about because we
said it is
who's we a black man who's that
who's we who is that who is that
hello yeah check your [ __ ] i'm talking
to one person
[ __ ] you up kevin
oh my god she was just saying that she
cheated [ __ ] you up
get this big [ __ ] look at this
that's why i just sat there and let her
talk
that's why i just sat there and let her
stupid ass talk this
is why you're dying alone i just let us
sit there and talk
i haven't found god ain't nobody rushing
to try to make
that was a stray no one's trying to make
stray fat girls their wives
that's why you have to pay for dick
that's why you got to pay me
to [ __ ] with you you got to take your
daddy's hard-earned money
to get somebody to even want to have sex
with your little chunky ass
ew oh that's not true that'll do it with
anything
and then you're mad because you get on
the program
and you make yourself look like the fool
you are
i'll just sit back and listen and strays
hang with strays
that's what it is strays hang with
strays
we'll [ __ ] you up think about this
this little butterball of a girl
actually has been cultured and
socialized and raised to think
that if she decided to stand in front of
a man she could do anything
more than just sit there and scream
seriously no this is actually really
true because i could
never imagine talking to someone or
acting that way
like that's crazy that that's like how
she interacts with people
like she's threatening a guy she doesn't
even know
this is where the modern woman is
do respect to the rest of you ladies
if you are dealing with women like you
you're beyond jokes at this point
it's not even funny anymore it's sad
that's why monique was
trying to make that heartfelt thing
because we've gone to the point
to where it's really just sad
no one takes you seriously because they
don't have to
that's why i don't take any particular
pleasure in actually showing i didn't go
looking for her
she came back looking for me to tell me
she's made a 360.
that's a nice dunk but you don't even
you're not even smart enough to know how
dumb you sound
i made a complete 360.
i realized i was out of control and i
didn't find a lord that i got myself a
man with money right now and
everything's okay
this is why people don't like christians
because
like literally two minutes ago she was
saying oh i found god
and then she's cursing him out five
minutes late that's why people have
issues with the church
now i wear a bonnet when i go outside
but
what's wrong with that i don't know
what's wrong with where the body you
trying to
i'm like not even gonna lie i think i'm
part of the problem
i don't wear like bonnets obviously
but i'll wear sweats i know i know i'm
part of the problem
tell me i'm ghetto what's ghetto about
that
what's ghetto about what i'm doing
what's going on kevin's kind of funny
what's ghetto about that huh i can't be
a lady
like this i mean i just wore my bonnet
every now and then
[Music]
i just bought it every night
man i'll [ __ ] you up you like boys
you got a [ __ ] you you got kittens
what you say girl yeah that's right
i told you once i'll make you famous
i ain't your daddy i wonder if girls get
like instagram followers after all days
i ain't your daddy you can tell i ain't
your daddy
because there's no way i'll let my
daughter get to be the size you are
i'd have took the chick-fil-a away from
your ass
that's right and i hope he sees the
videos sir
get your get little emmett under control
get the little fullback under control
because she's gonna roll out here and
say
something to the right man on the wrong
day
and she's gonna get herself hurt because
let me tell you something generation
x-men we just look at you and laugh
millennium men 50 50 but these gen z
guys
run it run that kind of look with these
guys and don't be surprised do you have
a skateboard hanging out the side of
your head
damn so congratulations
uh yeah you will be you will be on the
video
in about three hours on youtube we're
gonna cut and clip that
and put it i'm gonna put about let's put
about seven hundred dollars in marketing
behind that because
the sad part is you really think you're
doing something
that's the thing the person that gets
emotional
like on these lives that's the one who
looks stupid
what's wrong with me worrying about it
nothing
nothing at all ain't nothing at all
wrong with you wearing a bite
[Laughter]
and it's funny because it's true
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh here we go hold on ain't nobody got
time for that
i hate him oh i hate him
he didn't have to do her like that think
about it
one of these little butterscotch chunks
running around talk telling herself
she's a savage
i just got out of the shower what if i
were to run outside first off you ain't
going anywhere after the shower your fat
ass is too lazy to run anywhere
at best you walking you ain't running
nowhere
oh my god he does not like fat people i
swear to god
scoot over girl let me get in this seat
that's going up to carl's jr they got
the double ranch burger with onion rings
in here oh you can't make this [ __ ]
up hey man when you start you see the
thing is
uh little thickems has been allowed to
talk [ __ ] for too long
see that's the thing with pretty girls
especially like
i mean obviously she's not pretty
anymore but she had a nice face like you
could tell she probably once
was and a lot of times like
they have the nastiest attitudes because
just their whole lives they've been able
to
be as rude as possible and nobody
checked it used to be a time
where somebody would have taken from
simple to pee would have knocked the
furniture out of her mouth but that
little fool actually thinks she can talk
that way
and she's gonna she's campaigning for an
[ __ ] and she gonna get elected by the
one the right day
it's sad but it's true it's sad but it's
true
everybody we go you know what
i just remember who that was
remember otasia blunts
wings that was otasia
otasia i thought i got rid of you oh
y'all remember otasia and cornbread
that's who that was no i should react to
that video someone later occasionally in
cornbread
otasia and the other chick that was
cornbread
i got trolled by otasia and cornbread
wow well i'm gonna have to make about
rotation cornbread oh my god
okay let's get back to it comments off
comments on request to go live uh
off request to go live on
questions off there we go
oh tasia
[Music]
remember egyptian lover
i don't i don't know how to react to
this
i'm not even gonna lie it's kind of
weird sometimes how she sleep at night
[Music]
that's how she's sleeping like she gotta
sleep apnea she sound like egyptian
lover trying to sleep
digga digga digga
oh no don't don't freak out the dance
moves
don't do it
this is the weirdest live or the
weirdest
this is the weirdest one i've seen
badass bonnet badass bunny
[Music]
oh my god i gotta end it on that um
oh my gosh that was kind of funny um
kevin samuels is funny sometimes
that that was crazy because that girl
went did like a 360 like that or 180
like from being like nice to like crazy
in like two seconds
let me know in the comments um what you
guys agreed with and what you guys
disagreed with and
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell
guys i'm really trying to hit 20 000
subscribers each and every one of you
helps and i will talk to you guys next
time